alright alright what's up everybody
happy Tuesday how's it going hope you
all have had a wonderful start to your
day it's the afternoon now I have to
keep remembering that we now a stream at
2:00 p.m. instead of 11:00
I'm Persia max is back with his apex
legends just dropped another new update
event whatever you want to call it yeah
super big massive yeah a ton of stuff
has been dropped and changed and all
that jazz with this new update and we're
gonna talk about that a little bit while
you guys get into the chat and then
we're gonna play some good old apex what
changed here yeah they just released a
massive update all around the board not
only does it have a new limited time
mode and new skins you know stuff we're
used to seeing every single event but
they also made a bunch of balance
changes so these are really interesting
because some of them on paper sound
really crazy yeah some of them sound
dopey
yeah so much in the game when you
actually start playing exactly exactly
so some of those meta changes
bloodhounds scan increased by three
times so far now super far distance I
think I read somewhere how they wanted
to have bloodhound players use it to
scout out a town before going into it
instead of using it as a oh no who's
around me yeah what a sense I kind of
like that because like whenever I use it
as a cap annex can like I never really
helped me that much right next
and you're like okay they're right yeah
so this is like a pre-emptive okay I
know generally where they are I can like
to think ahead of time that's great but
then they also like increase his time to
activate yeah
[Music]
Gibby's gunship was reduced from seventy
five to fifty we've definitely been
seeing a lot of Gibby out and lately
with the buffs to his dome and all this
other stuff but you know I'm not mad at
that nerf because he was pretty broken
honestly like especially when the first
drop when nobody had shields yes 75
shields three on top of him whatever
body armor he already had he was just
like and it regenerated surprisingly
fast so I'm really not mad about that
nerve at all crypto also has a change
where whenever he is in the drone view
and it comes back out his primary weapon
not all of his weapons we were just
hoping for that gets reloaded that's
cool I'm also gonna put a link in the
chat to our article that has all of
these updates a few other updates that
are really interesting probably the
biggest ones that stand out to me is the
inventory update it's weird now mm-hmm
we have more slots in our backpack but
things are stacking differently and
stacking less high so to say one grenade
takes up one whole slot and no longer
stacks to each and stuff like that so
it's really interesting they did similar
things to the Med kits and the shield
batteries in the ammo and all that jazz
grenade stocks are one so it's kind of
rough for me so you can't grenade spam
anymore you just gotta like hold one per
stack and they take up a lot of it
Latorre space now so he just got to
really manage it well I think they were
going for less nade spam less reliance
on having a Watson on your team to
counter that and stuff so really
interested to see how it shakes up
obviously we're gonna get a better idea
of that once the event is over because
this event this deja loot event has
definitely shaken things up more than I
care to say but you know it is
definitely interesting it's also a harsh
reality of each
for someone like me who is like man RNG
is all these days and why I'm getting
bodied no it's not now that there's no
RNG it's worse for me yeah I think it's
mainly because I'm really bad at like
landings so people who are really good
at it and they have those optimal angles
and they can go quickly and land at the
perfect spot this mode is for you for
sure 100% and then there's just a lot of
other updates with this patch that you
guys should definitely check out quality
of life fixes a ton of bug fixes across
the board obviously they can't get them
all but they're definitely trying and I
respect that I think the biggest one is
dudes were working off for a while that
sounds like it's muzzle flash and that's
been reducing a lot which is great since
I know a lot of people complain about
that especially for guns that you know I
had really want the iron sights yeah 99
it's always been like I can't see
anything I'm shooting and then our next
topic really quick is that the file size
release of C game on its own exactly
I've been downloading games smaller than
this actually as of late for the PC and
the Xbox one it's about 32 and a half to
33 gigs and then for the ps4 it's about
18 and a half gigs still yikes
whoo that is a lot but they said that
they're going for that because they want
to hopefully make the file sizes smaller
in the future so I guess it starts with
one big chunky file size to have smaller
file sizes later yeah yeah and if you
guys would like to read more about all
of that there's the link in the chat so
yeah we aren't going to hop over to some
matches thank you guys so my oh the chat
is right which we didn't mention which
is actually huge the Evo shield oh yes
right the Evo shield is now a part of
Apex legends in the day djalu event and
it's a half of a level-one shield at the
start yeah
as you like start playing aggressively
and doing damage it'll just get more and
more powerful and more shield for you so
that's really really useful yeah
definitely more incentive behind sniping
and poking from a distance whereas you
know the meta right now you see someone
and you're like oh don't shoot him let's
get closer and then let's really take
him out because from a distance
there was really no incentive to make
yourself known or if you're a sniping
you snipe them you get that perfect
headshot they go down and then their
teammate just pick some up because you
farted get them anyways he just got
baited into their situation so it's not
really useful but but the emotions
actually like worth it knocks you
actually get that right back if you max
it out completely you get a red shield
which is stronger than a gold shield
yeah so maybe the all-father will be
nice to me and I will be able to get a
red shield at one point but until then
let's pop into the action thank you guys
for being patient and chill it let's do
this we can now look at the store really
quick to kind of see what the god rate
the bloodhound basically just belacan we
skinned and then we got some cool
banners I think that's he man are these
a part of it it's like the initial like
soared up in the air I feel like oh yeah
for sure
like a little transformers thing here
lit bumblebee what is that it looked
like it yeah I want to see that with his
new skin because it'll definitely be
yeah exactly like kind of cool gun skins
here but then we also got some diving
modes these are pretty cool too
Bangalore's trying to like shoot down
Kryptos drew that thing is so hard to
hit yeah this one's my favorite for sure
that is really really cool I think
that's my favorite so far that's a
really really digging the whole
aesthetic behind this event yeah red and
blue and it's like a little holographic
and reminds me of those retro like 3d
glasses used to get or like the whole
theme for this season actually not just
this event it's really cool
this is my favorite Bangalore skin for
sure yeah I got to see that even with
that skin I know every time I see this
octane one I'm I like it more and more
actually yeah all right oh hey just
joined
oh no it's eight minutes ago okay
all right let's do this
so where we are playing on ps4 today is
to brawl sir an Autobot or a Decepticon
Hey look he would be in Auto kostik he's
a Decepticon
[Music]
yeah revenant most he's the leader max
are you excited four kings canyon both
events that the kings canyon came back
up I was playing Max and they are so
good at playing Team Championship when I
went back I was like oh yeah I
definitely got this trade all the time
on this map and it wasn't until world's
edge came out where I really started
getting my badge on master yeah so going
back to it I was like yeah nothing's
changed
nothing I I'm still looking look at once
in a while that's more Eric's flavor
so I'm going here because I know there's
r99 right there and I like
and they were like one step ahead of me
not only both the guns on the way
is also not that great so I know the
general area where some things maybe
maybe you got a feeling someone's been
here 20 20s I don't have extended light
bag here just level one for some reason
gameplay any different the only
difference in this mode is that the
green locations and believe are all
the ring locations change
giving my shield to recharge this is not
the time to Landon oh he's getting
flanked he's getting flanked
[Music]
[Music]
I'll let you know if I see any seven
bullets like John wick oh snap my
damages all right well I've got 17
bullets also this the the circle is also
gonna land in the same place too right
interesting it is interesting because my
favorite place to land usually every
time you go this way and apparently
there's like nothing good there and it's
not in the rain because every time I've
landed there so far there's no there's
no one there has already been hit I'm
not sure if we should go this way yeah I
think a gold shield is definitely
somewhere in this town this one
epicenter and the other area I forgot
but oh I see them enemies I just saw
someone my golfing
oK we've got a team up there
[Applause]
we'd like to play the shooters on the
stream on console because it's just
easier for us to play together and
stream it at the same time game EPC is
[Music]
cat says what's our opinion on the Evo
shield
I don't think again is like it and then
you have to on top of like getting more
shields you have to seal up that shield
when you get it so you have like a
thousand damage not like a five level
feel
heal up all that day that's our French
we should grab early annoying I think
it's awesome to steal it from other
people when they have it leveled up but
it's like I kind of just don't wanna
take it on myself to like gain all that
way unless you're in a really good
sniping position to like c'mon that I
know there's another team here so I
don't know wait where did that respawn
bacon go
thank you all right let's see if I give
you sneaky enough
let's loot in my other buildings That's
Gary me can I get it okay I'm out Mac
sorry
I think there's a sniper in the I'm
literally on low IQ mode right oh yeah
I know they're trying to they must have
an Evo shield there's not a level of
because they're back they're amazing
so far it's something too confusing
that's really the best way to level up
that she didn't know of course you guys
aren't able to use it right it's not
meant for rushing down of crazy did not
say it that way but after he was like
duh I was like yeah you guys and this is
in the ring so you know those guys are
gonna
and nobody wanted to pick up a
peacekeeper shoddy huh let's see any
shotty ammo army what's the plan at this
point everybody's coming to us because
we are
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go here package being delivered
incoming care package that's the father
in that middle area on the top right did
they move and a spy on that area okay
Paul I wish I was Pathfinder I would
just put a zip line straight up to their
ending this is why I lose all the time
we got the champion found let's go this
right rotating
say move it my god is that what Hawking
says he says scoot and looting yeah give
it to Lou and then he goes see me
ruining my life yeah I were like drop
all the shield cells and then you just
ran by and picked up the med kit I
wanted at is asking prowler or our 99 I
will go with our 99 myself because I
don't know it's easier to use second of
all it just does more damage and now
it's technically it is strong and I know
yeah I mean if I have a select-fire I'm
Way more than use prowler but for some
reason the bursts on that gun yeah yeah
yeah without select-fire it is pretty
trash I see so many Evo shields just
abandoned and on the
no one is about that life I think it I
think it needs to be a white armor off
Howard obviously but yes if it was a
regular like 50 armor yeah at least at
least only 30 seconds left on the clock
the Rings close bait traps I think
there's a trap around here I find it
hard to believe that squad is gonna
stand there kiddin have been stabbed
much look over there
[Music]
I don't know where they are either
I will drag I'm desperate to have like
an extended mag with that gun yeah
there's a great is that your portal okay
pick that up from someone or if he was
he's really just tearing in love right
now
Oh somebody in this building possible
right here okay giving my shield to
recharge 45 seconds still ring close
amigos go huntin 30 seconds until the
ring closes you're like cutting a closer
I see an open door
[Music]
oh they're fighting someone else now
okay
very good this way I need to get to that
building fire
[Music]
[Applause]
to recharge
[Music]
camping there the entire game because
they know that they know the ring
[Laughter]
grenade need to recharge my shields
one-minute rings pretty close
all right good
[Music]
[Music]
it was like this team drop and they just
stayed over there the entire time but I
get it I wanted to switch things up I'm
sure they've been hearing nothing but
complaints all day and night about how
people never get any loot or whatever
you're like here fine try this prove to
us why we have our system yeah this
Elise is like reminded me how much I
appreciate a regular mode yeah I think
yeah like get getting like specifically
specific places I think the days that
you're getting drops and then like the
orangey is just like completely messing
with you and you'd seen no guns for life
hours on end that's what I'm like okay
maybe it's like obviously keep it
some days I'll go like three or four
games
if the havok underrated I don't know I
think it's rated exactly where it needs
to be balanced right now I think the
only thing that I've always wanted since
date this is what she was like fire was
added to it nobody you barely hear that
it's a very iconic sound to look once
you hear that go on sounds really cool
but I never hear anybody use that gun
because the shot is still delayed right
no it's a hits game so it takes a long
time to charge up but once it go then
it's game weapon so it goes immediately
crossing the entire matter but it takes
a long time to shoot and only does 60
oh I'm the dumb master crap oops I
didn't even notice
got a good feeling about this area yeah
hold your breath if you have to breathe
Eric is indeed in the office who's now
in our party get these dubs
all right well now we know where the
ring is
like the nevermind oh they're under me
caustic traps
it'll be taken down late
[Music]
I was just matching syringes I got that
voice clip which happens
oh wait what
copy dad okay I am repairing myself
sure I didn't think but
maybe they ran towards or maybe are
coming from oh yeah right here right
here contact with hostile get something
golds yeah I know okay
need to recharge my shields
I need it thank you
Arion so I'm taking Dryden's advice I
got the Evo shell I'm gonna Snape I've
ended up to level 2 ohms
I have no shield so if I do level it up
again I'm gonna be okay thanks TV
[Music]
so kind of worried because that last guy
he got down he didn't get there lurkin
yeah they might have been waiting for us
to go away so it can grab his banner oh
no way no he he ragequit extended light
mag here level 2 I feel like we should
go towards okay his people over there me
over there
Oh a what oh oh yeah targets got a new
car
yeah
they see me down
giving my shields a recharge all right
I've leveled them my Evo shield the
level I think I think he's gonna try to
go around a gate you I'll drop down to
I'll drop down
listen let's move here
listen let's move here and distract them
[Music]
I feel like we should back up let's
explore this way
holy Sh
[Music]
maybe something good this way now we're
good we'll let those fools battle it out
anyone know any good landing spots with
this event I know where it goes field is
and it spit fire with purple magnets
that's about it are you talking about
the spider epicenter because that's the
one that I know has like a gold shield
and like a sniper and a heavy gun but
yeah I haven't discovered any other
really good gold drops yet but I feel
like they did a good job of balancing
out a little bit like wherever there's a
gold shield there's not like a ton of
lead for that
overpower to the one drop it makes sense
over there I'm not sure how to approach
this Lucas like
they probably have a ton of good loot
now you know what yeah someone's going
up here interesting I think someone's
targeting me
[Applause]
[Applause]
recharging my shield
let's go this way
yeah let's just get out of here
[Music]
shotgun ammo here body shield here
looking for some loot here shield cell
here recharge is there anyone in this
building I guess I mean issued Sofia
right now because we already know
next if this would go from purple to red
or purple golden then red I think I
don't know I think it's red from six and
seven I can't here are the gun fires
coming from do you know what other
squads left to squad this probably
drilling good we're inside lucky us so
this mode is called - Shalu it's
basically all the losses and specified
spots and it just keeps appearing there
yep so no art engine side of things
which is quite the difference
lost use blood fighting I can't tell
where that's coming from though do you
know where it's coming from
only one other squad left friend let's
win it still keep an eye on that spot
over there she's one squad left yeah
okay let's uh take a look yeah I am
curious over here contact with target
she's coming your way
[Music]
they can't because the pings are in the
way oh my god
[Music]
Bing I feel like I would have been able
to snipe her darn it those close so
second please
yeah darn I don't know like this I feel
like people have found like good like
routes fine lewd and have fights and I
just I just want to landed that area
anymore cuz I haven't found any good
routes over there yeah that's specific
building like the first three we landed
on I never really have found anything
good there so far yeah what's up Brandon
welcome back how's it going so close so
close but yeah gg gg 2nd place next
one's got to be number 1
[Music]
there we go but yeah a ton of changes
are in this update from look at the time
mode to new skins to new body shields to
all the evokes pretty cool yeah I got my
evo child up to level 4 I just needed a
little bit more damage to get it to read
but Alex please relax we're clearly not
going to invite you relax
comment to us
whose music is pretty good I do like the
new music I've been itching for some
good music because I don't they have
interesting glow this will show you a 20
kill game when you show us one first
[Laughter]
squad we got there is nothing better
than me now it's I know there's gold
shield literally in that get ready
[Music]
body shield here level one
I spent eight got this awesome gun
firing oh yeah
does ablute change everyday - I don't
think so I think it's just the ring
location in the path of the dropship
yeah I got that please just go play a
regular like
although I do respect them creating a
whole
let's go this way
no peer leader go on watch out I feel
like we should go to the right let's
explore this way oh that's fine I just
don't wanna get stuck on the other side
of this something good this way I want
to go in dude no you see someone close
to you let's go this way
I just don't like uttering fights yeah
you like so distracted and still in the
fight and all of a sudden I'm just
scaring them a little bit warning shots
oh okay I guess oh oh I see more people
behind us okay okay I don't know where
to go
we're gonna get pinched probably have a
charged up sentiment over there probably
hasn't periscope it's nothing like that
[Music]
oh you have the gold shield - I just hit
him for 63
yeah this mode is weird it's straight-up
weird I think this is just the apex dev
Singh
yeah no they're proving their brain yeah
it's like the true test of how good you
really are under pressure right it's
like drop in the hottest area because
you know guaranteed like old shield and
good Lutz gonna be there and look for
the best or land a little more on the
outside and work your way in but by the
time you get in everyone's gonna have
really really good [ __ ] you know so I'm
like yeah what's what's the best way to
approach this situation now sniping is
more of a thing I am noticing that
though yeah so that's actually a nice
little I was having an all-out sniper
battle against across the map a minute
straight
I appreciate that optimism Brandon
Chris says it's rough I know how it
feels I do I wish they had both maps
available at all times yeah intruder I'm
curious as to why they haven't gone that
route yet but lately they've been giving
us a lot of moments that I think it is a
seeming flight route yeah
all right let's let's try this spike
because I know a good place to land
see they know they know where they know
where the good stuff is
don't know where the guns are alright
shockingly no one that is right here
right here okay a lot less people
[Music]
I got that caustics oh hello I did 175
damage to that caustic how is that
possible that's like everything that's
all the help he was nothing healing up
in their town
so they didn't exactly say that the Evo
shields were gonna be a permanent thing
but they're definitely I guess testing
them out yeah they said that they were
listening to consumer feedback and
seeing if they liked it or not I like it
I'm kind of lukewarm about it again like
if there was a white shield from the
beginning that would like I'll be more
inclined to pick it up from the
beginning but like yeah you're like you
know or 99 on 89 to fight like against
each other and you have the Evo show
that's not leveled up like you're just
colors right I like it to an extent I
feel like there's maybe like one or two
things that I would like for Rick to
like be buffed a little bit like
starting out as normal white level and
then when you level it up like let's say
you get all your shields knocked out and
you just have an empty bozo lon and then
you level it up they should at least
give you one bar I know at least one bar
of iron like don't be stingy you don't
got to give me the whole shield leveled
up and full I get it that would be too
cheap I understand but just give me one
I think at least like it should ramp up
more like it should be like a hundred
damage to get like a level two and then
like isn't it 200-300 I know it's like a
100 right now and it's like the level
one but maybe just like a slightly
higher ramp from the beginning and then
like to get like the max max show they
did you like you know 2,000 km or
something yeah maybe start at 150 to
level up yeah
never push a caustic yeah no there's
been so many times I'm like I want to
chase them and then I just see the cloud
I'm like alright well there goes that
idea
I also I was getting shot from somewhere
I couldn't hear I can't hear anything
right now
like down that caustic easily yeah we
got a third phrase even
which direction the buildings that we
came around surprisingly
like that yeah that direction behind
this because I knew Tate was fine me so
I didn't look that way and then as we
were all pushing in
Marlette knows I'm getting sonar
detected left and right now
nowhere is safe you don t need it fast
fast fast
because even when you're not using by
the Joma you get a really good field of
u2's yeah the game lasted for pretty
long - come on now bring it hey Jess say
we'll be waiting for the train yard -
[Music]
but we're low it
[Music]
sergeant's
thank you I don't have any apex Funko
pops but I remember when they did that
dev stream and they showed them off I
thought that the Pathfinder went in the
bloodhound one was oh yeah no Funko pops
was like what were they called there's
some other ways or bez or some some
weird company name but they were really
cool I like that my final one was like
the h-e-b like yeah and then like the
Bloodhound one was really cool pose in
the Mirage one was with soap too but
that was just like straight from the
trailer only the season 3 trailer went
like Mirage
all right we gotta do this
got it do it
do watch my typos to get into that right
space because I went backwards I should
have played tight full I know I should
like where everybody I'll be Circuit
thinks about there are two purple
shields in those buildings down below
mirage we are introducing but are there
good the ones that are that has the jump
tower near or the buildings directly I
think it's probably those like half
covered buildings the nice
there was definitely people chilled over
there too because a lot of people in so
let's go if you have a respiratory
system
I just don't know where it is exactly
like me she like
[Music]
Oh your octane this game I was like I
heard some got a hop up here select fire
let's go here just what this for on the
wall keeps like changing shape that's
weird I was like I thought I'm a freak
me out
[Music]
yeah I think you need to do a thousand
total damage he gets the red shields and
the jam is against players who are
already down doesn't count we could just
walk it oh this is the buildings between
garage Hey starting off the season
filled the cargo bots yeah no not really
I don't know if it's just cuz I haven't
been looking out for them and I haven't
been landing in the usual places where I
would find me there's one flying around
here
[Music]
yes place is always spicy the SIBO
shields are littered everywhere really
no I don't see I bet you anybody who
really hasn't read at the end probably
picked up like a half way leveled winds
and then just finished it at least it
doesn't like he pick one up and it
adjusts to the damage you already did
then that would be really cheap like you
do a thousand damage and then you go run
and look up for level one one and it
does let me know yeah
[Music]
sounding like I thought that was a whole
lot there we go we're like oh I guess
he's going it
level two Evo chilled see I'm gonna pick
this one up
yeah now it's worth it that way yeah cuz
I already had a level 2 shield on so I
might as well yeah Wow ok now I have a
lot less work to do but like my level of
- Evo shield is still only a white show
yeah it's only 2 bars of arm right $231
yeah
so this care package all also drops in
the exact same place every time and oh I
didn't even stop to think about that oh
it had similar but not the same unless
this unless the Evo shield I don't know
unless somehow the blue level two does
have more yogurt
let's go over here now from there simply
deploy
yo I think all their squads have already
been through there no kill either lucky
us we are already inside the ring so
many horse bodies
a champion justice I don't want to start
they might not be very good getting my
steps in for the day there's a dip one
over here yo I think all their squads
have already been through they're not
gonna follow you
havock is not as good anymore about that
turbocharger takes too long for a
certain rush I agree that's a big reason
why I don't use it anymore because it
was super super good when you didn't
have to make sure the charge and now I
feel like I might as well just use an L
sir
you said it buffed it overall I wonder
what they change they said is that the
charge uptime is slightly faster well I
mean at least I did shorten it because I
felt like the fact that it has the same
exact charge at time with no
turbocharger it was gross let's do it
yeah there was even a glitch before the
previous patch would let you use it like
a turbocharger without you without doing
anything you just need a selective re
good like start charging up and then
switch to select fire and then it just
be like ready to go as a turbocharger
I know I'm just casually leading in the
middle of the field
devs didn't want me to grenade spam well
too bad I got like 19 grenades here
seeing all these better shields in mind
but I'm like no I will level up this Evo
don't slow down now
inventory update kind of sex oh I
definitely give it they're going for
okay of how the medes right now and if
any of you guys ever tune into like
twitch rivals you know damn well
everyone has a watson on their team
because people don't like to spam those
needs yep and I can definitely see it as
their attempt to just like shake things
up a bit here keep it fresh like I
appreciate the thought but they put into
it but I just personally don't like
I think it helps certain things and then
didn't help others overall just another
thing for us to get used to just got
used to that one a day to adapt max
adapts all right we need more excitement
I'm attacking someone out there most
likely
[Music]
why does she have a gold chilled of
course I hate that oh my gosh I had like
four revives in the last minute
[Music]
dang yeah I should have just found a
better shields I was determined to use
that Evo shields but I mean he's gotta
go don't rake in enough damage for that
unfortunately all right
this might be the last game of the
stream we'll see I know another second
place what is up with it we need to get
the W I mean there are a lot of sweaty
is right now there's like level 400
everywhere right now little spicy right
now I see Calvin talking that trash in
chat I bet you got body you one-on-one
it's all good keep talking to chat bro
go ahead go ahead I know akashi's losses
Ashford bow move me wish oh he said he's
stoked for cod war zone I definitely
Nobby you one-on-one come at me bro come
at me
the championship is ours all the marbles
are on this one right here introducing
your champion he said Adam on Xbox I
definitely know all right you mad right
now yo Detroit system oh I'm getting on
right now
on the console you're not even playing
on challenge me
the quickest way to get a feel like
heels and shield cells are scarce
in here there and here we syringe here
it's just on the move 99% of the time
we've got stuff for you man we have time
for one more
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
y'all are so funny
alright last last one the other day I
was playing at home it was already like
midnight and I was like all right I got
a stream in the morning last one yeah
ten last ones later
I like to 38 yeah I finally
it just happens like I know what I'm
doing we'll be back next week but only
for the day shall leave mode
not feeling the mode
anyways what inspires but it should be
exciting considering you'll have to do
the whole like learning process so where
everything is I think it's like the
first that's just your I stay or do they
like start to learn where things are and
then after that you pretty yeah not
today
got a good feeling about this area play
so I'm asking yeah that's fine
we go it's a long drop fun and I never
seen anyone go over here anymore anyway
to stuff
there's at least a couple level t-shirts
there's a purple field in the Train
better next
no I landed part L the app I'm out I
hear them moving
oh wait man this game loves to watch me
fail yeah you guys fighting
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a lot more crazy like ragdoll
physics on this game lately for some
reason like I kill someone gets me in
their box just we're dying these are our
trap
[Applause]
enemy taken out
on my sweet baby Jesus
we are portals need to recharge my
shield
they can have fun over it literally no
mo Tay but we are bleeding look it's the
red pulsating lines under I will burn
that location into my brain oh wherever
the next medkit years off of my life
right now
placing gas trap administering medical
aid
you know I thought I heard some feet but
it might have been tasty looking for
some loot here dig talking yeah alright
I might pick up a different gun because
I got one bullet in this space and
meatballs we go GTF out the game is
actually super cool a Kush for the
reference and thank you alright finally
[Music]
hang on to it
I don't know if that was from behind
here choke
now all the kinds of zip lines appeared
gonna spy on that area was trained hard
even lose nothing up here was a shot
come from I thought he came from the
other side of the tunnel but to get it
to famous last yeah yeah they're over
there they're still chillin over there
though
come on ya talkin over I'm self I came
here myself how do you have tooth it's
all that poison
here's the big lull before the storm
hey maybe we actually use the survey
begin actually that's really like
completely useless a force blocking this
huge circle they're probably all in
skyhook right now having a little
campfire yeah eating their s'mores
[Music]
I got Kelvin so get in the chat
train yards too hot yeah I didn't
realize the care packages we've dropped
the same area every time also I should
double-check to confirm that this loot
is exactly the same cuz there's two
things that were the same it's like a
gold site in there or something yeah but
before those like a different flight all
the sites on this side now okay they
just swap sides there
I just don't feel like I would have the
attention span to land in the last
circle area and stay a very big in the
entire game
hostile spotted they're probably
gatekeeping us all we could do is portal
out oh you're going I just put it there
to get them shook you know let's go this
way now you gotta get them the shuck a
little bit can't let them feel safe
she's missing everything right here she
hurtled in charging shields
I got you friend
no no close the door I just heard a
[Music]
subject
bodies you here
all right we're kidded right now any
shield salsa or any shield batteries
people over there also spotted
stabilizer here sonar detected yeah oh
wow really does oh that's too spicy are
you kidding me spotty the subject or are
they just long-distance poking each
other getting shot I forgot where the
last thing ended already definitely you
know what I do I'm gonna throw a portal
over here let's go this way follow the
tunnel great a check out right here
[Music]
we find ourselves inside the next ring
right here contact understood
[Music]
there's octane and I think of
[Music]
I don't know what happened but we did I
shot into the cloud but I think
by the apex champions that was almost
reach back to back
we did it all right you guys well we ran
a little bit over time but it was worth
it because we got the dub this time had
Oblast playing some apex with you max
and teh GG's and thank you guys for
tuning in and watching this game gets a
more and more fun every time I played it
even the modes that I'm like I still
have fun I don't know I'm addicted and I
don't care alright thank you guys so
much for tuning in don't forget every
weekday at 2 p.m. Pacific time is when
we go live right here on GameSpot so
make sure you're tuning in every single
weekday until
you